und dann hoffe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 9 abgabe einer
regierungserklärung durch den
bundesminister für wirtschaft für eine
energie zum jahreswirtschaftsbericht 20
21 sicher und stark in die zukunft für
die aussprache im einzel seien die
regierungserklärung wurde eine dauer von
60 minuten beschlossen und damit hat das
wort zur abgabe der regierung sich gegen
der bundesminister für wirtschaft und
energie peter altmaier
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ein jahr nach beginn
der pandemie präsentiert sich die
deutsche wirtschaft in einer robusten
jahr für manche überraschend robusten
verfassung und mit mut zur zukunft die
rezession im letzten jahr war stark die
zweitstärkste in der
nachkriegsgeschichte
aber sie wäre war weniger stark als von
fast allen befürchtet der aufschwung hat
im oktober früher eingesetzt als erhofft
und trotz des rückschlags bei der
pandemie bekämpfung geht dieser
aufschwung weiter und er wird auch in
diesem jahr weitergehen mit einem
wachstum von drei prozent
im nächsten jahr wird die deutsche
wirtschaft nach allem was wir wissen
ihre alte vor pandemie stärke wieder
erreicht hat und dennoch 50.000 toten
seit beginn der pandemie hunderttausende
erkrankte menschen die ihr liebstes
verloren haben und unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer die sich sorgen machen um
den fortbestand ihrer lebensleistung
ihres unternehmens und millionen von
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern die
sich sorgen machen ob ihre arbeitsplätze
auch in zukunft sicher sind sie alle
arbeiten gemeinsam ohne ideologie ohne
gegenseitige schuldzuweisungen ohne den
versuch
andere in schlechtes licht zu rücken
daran dass wir die größte
herausforderung die größte
bewährungsprobe seit wiederaufbau und
wiedervereinigung bestehen nicht nur
staatliche hilfen nicht nur nicht nur
die umstände und die erfolge in der
pandemie bekämpfung sondern eben auch
der einsatz der einzelnen ist ganz
entscheidend viele waren bereit für die
überwindung dieser krise auch ihre
ersparnisse einzusetzen
ihre rücklagen und in manchen fällen
sogar die mühsam aufgebaute
altersversorgung anzutasten
und deshalb können wir heute sagen ein
jahr nach der pandemie ist die substanz
der deutschen wirtschaft intakt ein jahr
nach der pandemie alles weniger
unternehmenszusammenbrüche gegeben als
im jahr davor
ein jahr nach beginn der pandemie hat
deutschland immer noch mehr
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigungsverhältnisse als zu
praktisch jedem anderen zeitpunkt in
seiner geschichte und dafür möchte ich
im namen der bundesregierung auch ganz
persönlich als wirtschaftsminister
all denen die daran mitgewirkt haben ein
großes dankeschön aussprechen und ich
darf ihnen versichern wir werden alles
tun damit sie zur bald ist vertretbar
ist ihre normale tätigkeit wieder
aufnehmen können
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
zur ehrlichkeit gehört auch und ich sage
dies ohne jede schuldzuweisung dass wir
deshalb so lange mit den schließungen
beschäftigt sind und deshalb den offenen
unternehmerinnen und unternehmern jedoch
alles getan haben um hygiene konzepte zu
erarbeiten sie umzusetzen ihre
unternehmen so zu verändern dass sie
menschen bedienen und umsätze machen
können ohne aus ihrer sicht
infektionsrisiken zu vergrößern dass wir
deshalb so lange schon im dritten monat
im lock down sind weil es in vielen
fällen auch nicht möglich waren
gemeinsam mit den verantwortlichen in
bund und ländern die notwendigen
massnahmen zu einem frühen zeitpunkt zu
ergreifen
ich habe als wirtschaftsminister immer
gesagt die pandemie ist zum einen eine
gesundheitliche herausforderung und
bedrohung
zum anderen ist sie die größte bedrohung
für das funktionieren der wirtschaft
überhaupt und deshalb ist die frage der
pandemie bekämpfung keine frage die
gegen die wirtschaftlichen interessen
gestellt werden kann sondern es ist eine
gemeinsame aufgabe je schneller wir die
zahl der infektionen auf ein
vertretbares maß zurück bringen
je mehr es uns gelingt die ausbreitung
der virus mutationen zu verhindern
je schneller es möglich ist die zahl der
toten zu reduzieren desto eher kann die
wirtschaft ihr volles potenzial wieder
entfalten und das soll meine damen und
herren müssen wir helfen
ich bin so wie die meisten meiner
vorgänger in diesem amt
ein überzeugter anhänger der
marktwirtschaft der sozialen
marktwirtschaft und ich bin kein freund
staatlicher interventionen durch
transferleistungen wo immer es geht
aber meine damen und herren wenn ein
unternehmen das im jahre 2019 umsätze
und gewinne gemacht hat im jahre 20 20
und 21 vor einem umsatzrückgang von 70
80 90 prozent steht
aufgrund der pandemie dann war dieser
unternehmer kein schlechter unternehmer
dann war sein unternehmen nicht
erfolglos sondern es war das virus das
die gesetze der marktwirtschaft außer
kraft gesetzt hat und deshalb ist es
selbstverständlich dass wir helfen und
dass wir dafür sorgen dass auch in
zukunft diese unternehmen eine
überlebenschance in deutschland haben
wir haben meine damen und herren seit
beginn der pandemie wirtschaftshilfen
von knapp 80 milliarden euro bewilligt
und ausgezahlt
die sofort helfen in der größenordnung
von 13 milliarden im april und mai
letzten jahres milliarden an krediten
über die kfw schnell kredite bis zu
800.000 euro gerade für die
mittelständler exportkreditgarantien in
milliarden grössenordnungen
steuerstundungen aussetzung von
insolvenz pflicht und insolvenzantrag
von insolvenzantragspflicht
entschuldigung und überbrückungshilfen
seit juni des letzten jahres und bis zum
juni diesen jahres um denen zu helfen
die ihre fixkosten eben nicht reduzieren
können und trotzdem ihre unternehmen
erhalten wollen ja und als der zweite
lok da und notwendig wurde im november
da haben wir dann zu einem mittel
gegriffen dass wir nämlich den
unternehmen die wir geschlossen haben
mit dem november hilfe und dezember
hilfe dann auch eine umsatz erstattung
von im vergleichs umsatz des letzten
jahres ermöglicht haben das hat es
bisher in der bundesrepublik deutschland
noch nicht gegeben ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich beim bundestag für die
bewilligten mittel und die am eine damen
und herren ich kann verstehen wenn
gastronomen hoteliers inhaber von
geschäften oder unternehmen mit
körpernahe dienstleistung
kulturschaffende wenn sie darauf warten
dass diese hilfen endlich ausgezahlt
werden wir haben von der novemberhälfte
die in einem umfang beantragt worden ist
von über 5 von über 7 milliarden euro
rund die hälfte ausgezahlt
das ist ein trost für all diejenigen die
ihre abschlagszahlungen bekommen haben
und auch ihre endgültigen bescheide
haben aber es ist überhaupt gar kein
trost für denjenigen der seit november
immer noch darauf wartet dass dies
möglich ist und deshalb verstehe ich die
unzufriedenheit der betroffenen aber ich
habe wenig verständnis dafür wenn dann
versucht wird mit den problemen die
damit verbunden sind und verbunden sein
müssen wahlkampfzwecke zu verfolgenden
politisches kapital zu schlagen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich bin ich bin gestern ich bin gestern
auch noch einmal mehrfach gefragt worden
war nicht daran wieso ich nicht
garantieren konnte dass die november
hilfe bereits vor ende november völlig
ausgezahlt ist ja das hat unter anderem
auch damit zu tun weil wir auf wunsch
der betroffenen die antragsfristen für
die november hilfe verlängert haben bis
zum 30
april weil viele steuerberater und weil
viele selbstständige und mittelständler
uns darum gebeten haben weil sie ihre
weil sie ihre antragsunterlagen nicht am
ersten tag der antragsfrist einreichen
konnten
und wir haben meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wird im prinzip der
abschlagszahlung und dadurch dass wir
für die ländern und gemeinsam mit den
ländern eine digitale plattform
eingerichtet haben ermöglicht dass eine
rekordzahl von hilfen in einer kurzen
zeit ausgezahlt worden ist wir sind
allerdings auch dem steuerzahler
verpflichtet
es werden helfende zahlt etwa im rahmen
der überbrückungshilfe von 1,5 millionen
euro im monat an ein einzelnes
unternehmen bei der umsatz erstattung
sind die beträge um die es geht noch
viel hören
und deshalb sind wir auch in der
verpflichtung im umgang mit diesen
hilfen so zu organisieren dass wir an
der überprüfung durch den
bundesrechnungshof standhalten und dass
missbräuche nach möglichkeit verhindert
werden ich kann allen betroffenen die
auf diese hilfen warten versichern von
dieser stelle aus dass wir alles tun
damit es so schnell wie möglich und so
wirksam wie möglich bei den menschen
ankommt und ich bedanke mich vom
deutschen bundestag für die bereitschaft
die insolvenz antragsfrist für
diejenigen unternehmen weiter
auszusetzen die einen hilfsantrag
gestellt haben das ist die klare
botschaft niemand der acht oder 14 tage
länger auf seine hilfszahlungen warten
muss muss deshalb insolvenz anmelden wir
werden dies gesetzlich in dieser woche
so regeln dass klar ist dass die
unternehmen geschützt sind und das ist
das mindeste was wir für sie tun können
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren 80
milliarden euro an hilfen für die
unternehmen zusätzlich 23 milliarden
kurzarbeitergeld zusätzlich ein
konjunkturpaket von 130 milliarden und
das was wir in den nächsten sechs
monaten november und dezember hilfe an
überbrückungshilfe drei bezahlen werden
wird sich noch einmal auf bis zu 50
milliarden euro subsumieren dieses geld
konnten wir auch deshalb in die hand
nehmen weil die finanzminister der
letzten 15 jahre
sie gehören unterschiedlichen parteien
an weil die mitglieder des deutschen
bundestages in den letzten 15 jahren
dafür gesorgt haben dass unsere
staatlichen finanzen solide und in
ordnung war und weil die beteiligten in
der wirtschaft die unternehmen und die
arbeitnehmer gemeinsam dafür gesorgt
haben dass unsere volkswirtschaften in
einer guten verfassung ist deshalb
können wir ihnen etwas von dem
zurückgeben was sie uns in der
vergangenheit gegeben haben ja und ich
sage das entree personell ganz
persönlich als wirtschaftsminister
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir beim
verlust rückgrat
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mutiger
gewesen wären aber manche fragen werden
auch mehrfach diskutiert und wenn man
nicht alles erreichen bei der bürokratie
entlastung und in anderen fragen was wir
uns vorgenommen haben dann ist es kein
grund die dinge schlecht zu reden
sondern einen ansporn uns dafür
einzusetzen um meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren jahre
wenn wir die unmittelbaren pandemie
folgen überwunden haben
dann müssen wir uns darauf konzentrieren
dass unsere wirtschaft sicher und stark
auch in der zukunft sein kann dass in
einem internationalen umfeld das rauer
geworden ist mit mehr wettbewerb und mit
mehr wettbewerbern mit einem enormen
technischen disruptiven
innovationspotenzial dass wir jeden tag
sehen im bereich der digitalisierung im
bereich der biotechnologie in vielen
anderen bereichen
dass wir dort weiterhin mit halten
können wie in den letzten jahren
wir brauchen entlastung der bürokratie
ich halte ganz persönlich
steuererhöhungen in der krise oder
unmittelbar nach der krise für keine
gute idee und ich glaube dass wir das
was wir investieren können noch so
ansetzen und anwenden müssen dass es
dazu beiträgt dass innovation möglich
wird deshalb investieren wir und ich
bedanke mich beim bundesfinanzminister
für die unterstützung in digitale
abschreibungen in digitale innovationen
von mittelständischen unternehmen die
programme sind vielfach überzeichnet wir
haben dann zehn milliarden zukunftsfonds
aufgelegt ich bedanke mich bei der
fraktion ganz herzlich für die
unterstützung wir haben mit dem projekt
garics die voraussetzungen geschaffen
für eine souveräne europäische daten
infrastruktur die elektromobilität und
alternative antriebe wasserstoff und
synthetisches prinz ihn und viele andere
kommen richtig in schwung und deshalb
werden wir nicht nur in die ladesäulen
infrastruktur investieren sondern wir
werden dafür sorgen dass die menschen in
deutschland auch einen anteil an der
neuen wertschöpfung der elektromobilität
haben vorgestern hat die europäische
kommission ein neues projekt im
gemeinsamen europäischen interesse unter
deutscher führung
ihr billigt und akzeptiert wo es darum
geht zehntausende von arbeitsplätzen in
europa zu schaffen viele davon in
deutschland
bei der produktion der modernsten
nachhaltigsten leistungsfähigsten
elektrobatterien die es weltweit gibt
wir sind das land der ingenieure wir
sind das land wo elektro akkumulatoren
vor über 120 jahren erfunden und
eingeführt worden sind und wir möchten
beim bau der modernsten der
nachhaltigsten der besten
umweltfreundlichsten autos und
klimafreundlichsten autos vorne mit
dabei sein und ein beitrag dazu leisten
dass deutschland das land der mobilität
und der automobilität auch in zukunft
bleibt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wir werden einige
herausforderungen haben im hinblick auf
freien welthandel im hinblick auf den
kampf gegen subventionen und
protektionismus wir werden dafür sorgen
müssen dass die deutsche volkswirtschaft
genügend fachkräfte zur verfügung hat
aber all dies ist möglich wenn wir uns
inspirieren lassen von der leistung
derjenigen die sich der korona pandemie
entgegengestemmt haben die dafür gesorgt
haben dass die lieferketten nicht
zusammengebrochen sind dass die
unternehmen eine chance für die zukunft
haben und wenn wir gemeinsam pläne
entwickeln wie wir klimaschutz und
wirtschaftswachstum zu einer mächtigen
synergie machen können wenn wir
gemeinsam im stande sind dafür zu sorgen
dass die deutsche volkswirtschaft eben
nicht nur in den bereichen wo sie immer
schon stark war dann auch in den
bereichen die die zukunft bestimmen
werden fuß fasst und ganz vorne mit
dabei ist dann ist mir für die weitere
entwicklung unserer wirtschaftskraft
nicht bange wir können uns vieles
erlauben solange wir über eine
funktionierende soziale marktwirtschaft
und eine erfolgreiche florierende
volkswirtschaft verfügen wir können uns
vieles leisten im umweltschutz in der
bildungspolitik in der
gesundheitspolitik in der infrastruktur
solange wir die notwendigen einnahmen
erwirtschaften und es geht nur mit einer
guten wirtschaft diese erkenntnis hat
sich in der pandemie herumgesprochen
und sie gehört zu den wenigen positiven
nebenerscheinungen einer der größten
herausforderungen unseres landes aber es
ist eine gute ausgangsbasis dafür dass
wir auch im nächsten jahr positiv über
den stand der deutschen wirtschaft und
über ihre zukunftsaussichten werden
sprechen können vielen herzlichen dank
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
hat hier noch einmal den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht vorgestellt die
prognose muss gesenkt werden von der
habsburger 4,4 angenommen jetzt auf drei
prozent aber peter altmaier das war viel
wichtiger hat hier erklärt dass niemand
insolvenz anmelden muss der bisher noch
kein geld bekommen hat
dieses geld wird gezahlt werden und
deswegen braucht also keine insolvenz
anzumelden in den nächsten 14 tagen drei
wochen soll das geld kommt dem 34
der minister sie sprechen von einer
wirtschaft in robustem zustand das ist
ja wohl wirklich ein witz und die
schätze tausende haben da draußen jetzt
mit dem kopf geschüttelt die um ihre
jobs um ihre unternehmen bangen
das ist weiß gott nicht robust robustes
offensichtlich allein der wille der
bundeskanzlerin diesen lockdown ewig
weiter zu treiben frau bundeskanzlerin
sie haben wohl gesagt wir müssen noch
strenger werden
das macht den menschen angst da draußen
die um ihre jobs fürchten und wir sagen
dazu schneiden wir halten das
wirtschaftlich auf dauer nicht durch
deutschland braucht endlich eine neue
strategie wir müssen unsere senioren
insbesondere in den heimen endlich
konsequent schützen aber unsere
unternehmen müssen wieder arbeiten
dürfen
wer soll dann bitteschön den staat
finanzieren wenn keiner mehr was
erwirtschaftet
oder ich erlebe es in meinem wahlkreis
an der ostsee viele touristiker fragen
wann können wir dann endlich wieder
urlauber empfang wann können wir endlich
unsere läden aufmachen fragen die
einzelhändler es macht mürbe auf die
dauer die wirtschaft braucht endlich
eine verlässliche und schnelle öffnungs
perspektive herr altmaier
sie haben gesagt wir werden alles tun
damit kein arbeitsplatz und kein
gesundes unternehmen wegen corona
schließen muss und verloren geht
das war natürlich ein hehres ziel aber
sie sind krachend gescheitert die zahlen
sind deutlich im letzten jahren wie eine
halbe million mehr arbeitslose im
schnitt gehabt und das ifo institut
schätzt bis zu 750.000 unternehmen
existenzieller not es knirscht also
immer lauter im gepäck und das können
wir nicht auf dauer mit immer neuen
überbrückungshilfen übertünchen oder
dagegen hilft schon gar nicht nach vogel
strauß methode einfach die
insolvenzantragspflicht immer weiter
auszusetzen
ich kann es ja verstehen dass sie sich
über die nächste wahl retten wollen
aber sie schaden damit unserer
volkswirtschaft sie schaden damit unsere
noch einigermaßen gesunden unternehmen
und es war eben diese bundesregierung
kaltmeier die es nicht geschafft hat
gerade den kleinunternehmen mit den
november und dezember helfen wirklich
schnell unter die arme zu greifen
das liegt im wesentlichen wohl nicht in
ihrem ressort das kann man sagen aber es
ist ihre bundesregierung die das getan
hat und am anfang der pandemie kann man
sicher softwareprobleme noch vorstellen
aber nach einem dreiviertel jahr dass da
immer noch nichts klappt das grenzt an
total versagen und wo sind die
begleitenden strukturellen
verbesserungen diese hätten treffen
können
die jetzt wirklich sinnvoll wären wir
haben es gefordert warum lassen wir die
gesenkte mehrwertsteuer nicht da wo sie
im letzten jahr war das war ja ein
richtiger schritt warum könnten wir das
nicht weiterlaufen lassen
warum haben die stromsteuer nicht längst
aufs minimum gesenkt warum haben wir die
steuerlichen verlust rückt rege eben
nicht deutlich ausgeweitet das alles
hätte kommen müssen und ihre
bundesregierung hat es nicht geschafft
stattdessen streiten sie über
steuererhöhungen obwohl so groß scheint
der streit zu sein zum ersten januar
haben sie ja die spritsteuern erhöht die
mehrwertsteuer wieder angehoben also es
scheint der streit da wirklich nicht
groß zu sein
allein der gedanke an steuererhöhungen
in dieser zeit ist ein affront gegenüber
den schon ohnehin gebeutelten bürgern
meine damen und herren der ewige locker
und ruiniert unser land solo
selbständige einzelhändler gastronomen
hoteliers sie alle wollen endlich wieder
ranklotzen dürfen und wir müssen endlich
dazu kommen dass dieser locker und jetzt
endlich ein ende hat schützen wir unsere
senioren in den heimen aber lassen wir
die wirtschaft unsere menschen im land
endlich wieder arbeiten dankeschön
[Applaus]
der bundestag debattiert über den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht 20 21 und der
nächste gegner ist der fdp fraktions und
parteivorsitzende christian lindner
[Applaus]
da haben uns jetzt hier ein wenig vertan
das ist jedenfalls nicht christian
hinten sehr geehrter herr präsident
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die heutige debatte zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht findet in einem
ganz anderen umfeld statt als die jahre
zuvor
die korona pandemie der klimawandel der
zunehmende wettbewerb durch
globalisierung aber auch die
demografische entwicklung machen
besondere politik und besondere konzepte
notwendig sie sind herausfordernd diese
themen und deshalb werden wir genau
daran setzen auch lösungen zu finden
es ist es ist deshalb heute eine
beratung nicht nur zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht sondern über
den zustand über die perspektiven und
erwartungen an wirtschaft gesellschaft
und politik
die heutige generation verfügt über
möglichkeiten und chancen über können
wie keine generation zuvor wissen
technologie innovation bildung und
forschung eröffnet uns enorme
perspektiven für eine
verantwortungsvolle politik und wir
sitzen besitzen
die politische kraft und die
wirtschaftliche stärke gemeinsam in
europa den internationaler
zusammenarbeit dafür zu sorgen dass ein
leben in würde gelingt das arbeit
zufrieden und nicht krank macht das
klimaneutrales wirtschaften möglich und
eine solidarische gesellschaft
realisierbar sind
die spd hat wie keine andere partei in
über 150 jahren ihrer geschichte und
auch in ihrer erfahrung die organisation
von veränderungen sehr erfolgreich
bewältigt und die notwendigkeit für den
tief greifenden wandel ist für uns keine
neue erkenntnis als sozialdemokratinnen
und sozialdemokraten haben wir den
menschen sicherheit im wandel
versprochen
aber die zeiten ändern sich und heute
wissen wir genau das ohne einen wandel
in der politik und in wirtschaft und
gesellschaft und so wie wir unseren
konsum organisieren die zukunft nicht
gestaltbar ist wir wissen heute genau
dass es nur eine sichere perspektive für
arbeitsplätze und für wirtschaft gibt
wenn sie mit den klimaverträglich
organisiert wird und daran müssen wir
arbeiten meine damen und herren
deshalb sagen wir nichts sicherheit im
wandel sondern sicherheit durch wandel
und das wird die aufgabe der 2020er
jahre sein
kern der sozialen und ökologischen
modernisierung der wirtschaft ist der
erhalt und der ausbau von sozialer
gerechtigkeit auch von mitbestimmung von
tarifbindung von teilhabe von guter
arbeit schutz des klimas und der umwelt
und natürlich auch stärkung anderes
innovationsfreundliche umfeldes und des
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalts der
diesjährige jahreswirtschaftsbericht ist
ein beweis für die wirklich agile
zustand unserer wirtschaft und das kann
auch mit den reden der afg hier nicht
schlecht gemacht werden ich weiß dass
sie interesse haben einen schlechten
zuständen wir haben einen guten
zuständen ein interesse und deshalb ist
unsere politik eine andere als
hier vorgetragen wichtig waren natürlich
auch die hilfsprogramme die zur
unterstützung der wirtschaft auf den weg
gebracht worden sind und es waren die
erfahrung und die kompetenz von olaf
scholz die richtigen instrumente für die
wirtschaft entwickelt haben es waren
hubertus heil als arbeitsminister der
mit dem kurzarbeitergeld genau das
richtige instrument auf den weg gebracht
hat um den arbeitsmarkt zu stabilisieren
und die menschen im job zu halten das
war das ziel dass wir das gemacht haben
und spätestens jetzt wird doch allen
klar dass das zwei seiten einer medaille
sind auf der einen seite ein starker
handlungsfähiger staat und auf der
anderen seite die wirtschaft und genau
diese kooperation dieses gegenseitige
vertrauen ineinander hat dafür gesorgt
dass wir mit dieser wirtschaft heute so
dastehen und deshalb finden wir die
richtigen ansätze im
jahreswirtschaftsbericht und ich freue
mich dass auch die globalen
nachhaltigkeitsziele erwähnt worden sind
ich bin mitglied im parlamentarischen
beirat für nachhaltige entwicklung genau
aus diesem grund weil wir diese
verknüpfung hier organisieren
in dieser politik und deshalb sind
investitionen auch weiter in
infrastruktur in bildung in
klimaneutrale antriebe und kraftstoffe
aber auch den zügigen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und den hochlauf
der wasserstoffwirtschaft jetzt zu
organisieren
genau das wird die industrie in
deutschland halten das wird genau
unseren wirtschaftsstandort
stabilisieren
für uns als spd ist klar herr kollege
herr präsident ich sehe schon die us
irgendwie schneller heute vielen dank
gekommen ist
sorry also für uns als spd steht klar
dass wir die korona programme für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer für
die familie und die wirtschaft so lange
daran festhalten wie es notwendig ist
und sie können sich darauf verlassen
dass die spd der partner ist für die
menschen in diesem land die sich auch
aus der krise heraus für den herzlichen
dank ja man kann natürlich kein christ
fall von der spd wir noch einmal gesagt
hat sicherheit durch wandel erhalt und
ausbau der sozialen gerechtigkeit das
ist der zentrale punkt für die
sozialdemokratie ja und der von mir eben
schon angekündigte christian der hat
jetzt gleich das wort partei und
fraktionschef hier auch für uns jetzt
das wort den fraktionsvorsitzenden der
fdp christian lindner herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen am
dienstag ist ein streitgespräch zwischen
minister altmaier und mir im
handelsblatt erschienen und in dieser
begegnung hat herr altmaier einmal mehr
sein wirtschaftspolitisches wirken und
die wirksamkeit der hilfen der
bundesregierung gelobt und die
leserinnen und leser musst nur ein paar
seiten weiter blättern und da lassen sie
den dringenden appell des unternehmers
thomas althoff der sich um sein
lebenswerk betrogen fühlt weil hilfen
nicht fließt gestern stellt peter
altmaier den jahreswirtschaftsbericht
vor und zeitgleich meldet sich der
jaguar der geschäftsführer des
bundesverbandes mittelständische
wirtschaft zu wort und spricht davon
diese bundesregierung befinde sich in
einem konjunkturpolitischen winterschlaf
heute stellt sich peter altmaier ihr hin
und spricht von einem robusten wachstum
und heute in den zeitungen lesen der vom
baden württembergischen unternehmer
roland mack bei dem noch gar nichts
nicht nur an hilfen angekommen ist der
gar keine möglichkeiten hat hilfen in
anspruch zu nehmen
herr kollege altmaier die wahrnehmung
wie sie haben und die realität im land
klaffen immer weiter auseinander
diese schere sollten sie schließt und
nun sprechen sie hier
und sprechen sie hier tatsächlich von
einer robusten wachstums perspektive gar
von einem aufschwung der alemannia das
markttechnisch natürlich stimmen aber
bestimmte branchen haben die auch enorm
an marktanteilen gewinnen ich denke an
den online handel
die kehrseite werden der möglicherweise
aber in einigen monaten in unseren
innenstädten beobachten können wir haben
viele unternehmen die fürchten ob sie
überhaupt eine fortsetzung perspektive
haben weil die von ihnen gerade hier
gerühmte aufhebung der
insolvenzantragspflicht kurzarbeitergeld
das hoffen auf hilfen diese unternehmen
noch in einer schwebe lage hält aber die
verdeckten risiken in der deutschland
bilanz werden von tag zu tag größer
deshalb ist jetzt entschlossenes handeln
erforderlich und dazu haben wir ihn ja
in den vergangenen monaten wiederholt
vorschläge gemacht
unser kollege christian dürr schon ich
glaube im april des vergangenen jahres
mit der dringenden warnung den
steuerlichen verlust rücktritt möglich
zu machen das heißt die verluste des
jahres 2020 oder 21 zu verrechnen
gegenüber der steuerschuld der vorjahre
er alt man ja sie haben die sie in der
heute auch für sich mit reklamiert und
verweisen dann auf die spd also muss man
doch öffentlich frage was hält die
sozialdemokratie ab dieses instrument
einzusetzen weil es eine schnelle
liquiditätshilfe für die gesamte
wirtschaft bedeutet ohne dass dem staat
irgendeiner einnahme entgeht war nämlich
sonst die verluste die zukunft weiter
getragen würden der einzige unterschied
ist es wurde dann auch betriebe in der
zukunft geben und nicht viel mehr
pleiten bei kollegen michael theurer hat
bei so vielen gelegenheiten über ihre
überbrückungshilfen gesprochen
die überbrückungshilfe 3d dem handel im
dezember helfen sollte die kann man
heute im januar überhaupt noch nicht
beantragen
herr altmaier trotzdem erwähnen sie hier
also müssen wir doch hier
andere instrumente nachdenken und
kollege teure hat vorgeschlagen gestern
noch mindestens auch rückwirkend zu
ermöglichen sich nicht an umsatz und
fixkosten und so weiter zu orientieren
sondern ganz einfach das
betriebsergebnis der vorjahre zur
grundlage zu machen und dann
unbürokratisch und schnell hilfe aus
zusammen um bei kollege johannes vogel
der so oft über solo selbstständige
gesprochen hat die diese bundesregierung
auf die hartz iv behörde verweist stadt
ein unternehmer lohn auszuzahlen der im
übrigen nicht nur eine frage der
wirtschaftlichen sicherung sondern auch
des respekts wäre nun all das finden wir
gegenwärtig bei ihm nicht heute morgen
lese ich auf den ticker dass der
minister jens spahn jetzt offen ist für
einen impf gipfel
das haben wir hier im haus schon länger
vorgeschlagen mit allen beteiligten an
einen tisch zu kommen und zu schauen was
noch zu retten ist erst dann auch herr
reuter der spd ministerpräsident von
brandenburg heute die umkehr bei herrn
sparen
offensichtlich sind ja auch viele
zusagen bzw erwartungen geäußert worden
sind nicht so eingetroffen ist zum
beispiel wochen lang nein es kann kein
anderes pharmazeutisches unternehmen
biontech im stoffe produzieren genau das
macht nun sanofi also macht schon sinn
mit der branche übrigens auch mit dem
niedergelassenen bereich mit landkreisen
zusammen zu kommen und zuschauen wie
kann schneller geimpft werden gut dass
es diese wende gibt
gut dass es diese wende bayern sparen
geht herr altmaier herr scholz wir
würden sie aber auf urheberrechtsschutz
nicht verklagen wenn sie auch andere
ideen von uns aufnehmen würden in der
wirtschafts und finanzpolitik
und vor allem brauchen wir eine das ist
ja klar eine perspektive auf eroeffnung
schleswig holstein hatten einen
vorschlag für einen perspektivspieler
gemacht der nach einer klaren wenn dann
regel öffnung ermöglicht kitas und
schulen dann auch schon handelt der
einst gastronomie ich verhehle nicht ich
glaube dass man mit innovativen
maßnahmen von luftreiniger und einsatz
der bundeswehr und ihrer freiwillige
dass man dass man noch ambitionierter
vorgehen könnte als die koalition in
kiel
aber auch frau bundeskanzlerin an sie
gerichtet wenn sich eine koalition von
cdu grünen und fdp mit allen
kompromissen auf einem perspektiv plan
verständigt dann ist das
richtungsweisend für die ganze republik
und sollte es auch für ihr handeln im
bund sind und nun und nun schauen wir
nach vorne wie kommen wir aus dieser
situation raus es gibt vorschläge aus
der union schuldenbremse zu modifizieren
also höhere schulden mit der union aus
der spd gibt den vorschlag die steuern
zu erhöhen was ein konjunkturprogramm
die grünen haben sich mit ihrem
grundsatzprogramm auf beides verständigt
also höhere schulden und höhere steuern
warum versuchen das nicht einfach mit
einer wachstums und
wirtschaftsfreundlichen politik ohne
höhere schulden auf dauer ohne höhere
steuern
und das tut not der kollege brinkhaus
hat vor einer woche ja völlig zu recht
gesagt im grunde müsste in diesem sommer
noch gehandelt werden die europäische
union unterstreicht das weil sich
deutschland selbst für die partizipation
am aufbau vom noch nicht qualifiziert
hat wegen der defizite bei
digitalisierung bildung und höre und
staune wegen der zu hohen steuer- und
abgabenlast also sollten wir hier
ansetzen und das rasch stattdessen gibt
es damit komme ich zum schluss
stattdessen gibt es ein buntes füllhorn
hier auch heute wieder von
unterschiedlichen investitionen
maßnahmen programme und progrämmchen
hier und dort
diese programme haben einen mangel oft
genug fließt das geld nicht ab vom
konjunkturprogramm das im vergangenen
jahr mit 10 milliarden euro ausgestattet
worden ist sind bis dato erst 800
millionen euro abgeflossen
man kann auch nicht immer sicher sein
dass man auf das richtige pferd setzen
wir werden ja sehen was der zukunft
antrieb sein wird ist es vielleicht der
batterie elektrische antrieb manches
spricht dafür
oder ist es nun mindestens teilweise
nicht auch der verbrennungsmotor mit
synthetischen kraftstoff von dem in
baden württemberg viele arbeitsplätze
abhängen und diese technologie wird ihr
euch die eur 7 normen erschwert also man
kann es politisch seiner regierung nicht
wissen und deshalb wäre es sinnvoll
durch bürokratieabbau geringere
energiekosten entlastung bei den steuern
die angebotsbedingungen für die
wirtschaft zu verbessern damit wir als
investitionsstandort attraktiv werden
tagesschau.de
schreibt aber heute in einem porträt
über den bundeswirtschaftsminister
angesichts seiner vielen subventionen
programme und progrämmchen er sei kein
ludwig erhard und die war altmaier ich
weiß nicht wie sie dazu stehen ob sie
sich selbst in der tradition vernünftig
aussehen oder nicht andere tun es nicht
eines wissen wir aber ein möglich erhard
der sich um standortbedingungen bemüht
den könnte unser land heute gut
gebrauchen
bis dahin war dass wir brauchen eine
perspektive auf öffnung hat er gesagt
und sich hinter den plan von
schleswig-holstein gestellt die
bundeskanzlerin aufgefordert sich das
anzuschauen und vereinigungen sie in den
betrieben in deutschland aber auch den
menschen eine klare perspektive auf den
weg mitzugeben wie es weitergehen soll
carsten lindemann jetzt
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der cdu csu und vorsitzende der
mittelstands- und wirtschaftsingenieurs
wirtschaftsbericht des vergangenen
jahres angesehen
wir haben uns fast exakt vor einem jahr
hier getroffen haben den diskutiert
damals war die rede von einer fragilen
konjunkturellen lage
danach kam die dampfwalze namens corona
es war ein externer schock
übrigens weltweit manchmal habe ich den
eindruck wenn der ein oder andere
geredet dass es ein deutsches problem
wäre dass wir hier irgendwie was gemacht
haben und deshalb jetzt hier die
probleme haben dass ein externer schock
und verschuldet weltweit auf uns
zugekommen
wir sind verdammt noch mal alle in der
verantwortung das beste für dieses land
zu wollen damit wir da wieder rauskommen
natürlich konnten wir die prognosen
nicht halten
die arbeitslosenzahlen sind gestiegen
und nicht gesunken nie vorgesehen
wir sind ausgegangen von einem prozent
wachstum - 5 und wir haben im letzten
jahr seit jahren zum ersten mal die
maastricht kriterien eingehalten nicht
nur die drei prozent sondern auch das
wichtige maastricht kriterium für mich
das wichtigste
die schulden im verhältnis zum
sozialprodukt auf unter 60 prozent zu
drücken
das war die leistung ja dieser
bundesregierung übrigens nicht nur
dieser übrigens auch der letzten jungs
auch die leistung mit ihnen mit der fdp
der letzten zehn jahre
das wir gezeigt haben mit
haushaltskonsolidierung kann man
gleichzeitig wachstum schaffen und
dieses land in die zukunft führen
und genau da müssen wir wieder hin wenn
wir aus dieser krise erfolgreich
rauskommen wollen
brauchen wir haushaltskonsolidierung und
damit auf den wachstumsweg umgang mit
auf den wachstumsweg zu gehen und
zusätzlich und zusätzlich brauchen wir
vier punkte neben dieser aufsatz
konsolidierten der erste punkt die
wirtschaftshilfen
ja auch ich kriege die anrufe lieber
christian lindner die kriegen die alle
von der messe bauern von den friseuren
von den einzelhändlern von den
restaurantbetreibern von allen wo bleibt
das geld ja aber ich finde es falsch und
auch nicht redlich die schuld
ausschließlich hier im boden zu sehen
ich komme selbst aus nordrhein westfalen
ich weiß selbst was herr pinkwart für
eine politik macht übrigens eine sehr
gute als wirtschaftsminister otto
mitfahren ja und die regierung von armin
laschet war es übrigens auch die den
letzten wochen bekommen müssen hat
gesagt wir müssen die programme
überarbeiten
wenn der einzelhandel nicht mehr
arbeiten kann der stationäre der braucht
er unterstützung nämlich dass wir die
saison war als fixkosten zumindest
anteilig an rechnen
und dadurch dass die nordrhein westfalen
auf uns zugekommen sind mit richtigen
argumenten die die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion unterstützt
hat mussten wir dieses programm
überarbeiten und dadurch zieht es sich
immer weiter hin
am ende des tages sind sie natürlich
auch in den ländern vertreten auch die
grünen aber ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich
der friseur der einzelhändler der
messebauer der veranstalter der
eventmanager der solo selbstständige der
kulturschaffende der interessiert sich
nicht dafür ob unschuld estland schuld
ist oder was auch immer
sondern das geld muss auf seinem konto
und deswegen danke peter altmaier die
hälfte ausgezahlt
die andere hälfte muss jetzt in den
nächsten wochen kommen der zweite punkt
wir brauchen eine bessere
verlustverrechnung das konzept da
christian and nach völlig recht ist
marktwirtschaft pur weil es genau die
unternehmen trifft die in den letzten
jahren erfolgreich war und wir dürfen
den zusammenhang nicht aus den augen
verlieren die beschäftigten in
deutschland der mittelstand in
deutschland zahlen steuern mit diesen
steuern können unsere infrastruktur
unsere bildung und vieles mehr
finanzieren
und deshalb müssen wir bei diesem punkt
weiterkommen und herr scholz sie müssen
ihr veto bei diesem punkt aufgehen es
ist nicht groß haushalts relevant
sondern das geld kommt durch höhere
steuern zurück der dritte punkt jahre
brauchen eine perspektive für die
wirtschaft die mutation ist da völlig
berechtigt auch die große sorge trotzdem
brauchen wir pläne stufen pläne damit
die wirtschaft weiß wenn die zahlen
weiter singen wenn die situation gut ist
unter welchen bedingungen ich wann
öffnet kann vierter punkt wenn wir
wirklich durchstarten wollen dann müssen
wir wissen dass wir rahmenbedingungen
schaffen eines der wichtigsten
rahmenbedingungen meines erachtens sind
die rahmenbedingungen in bezug auf
digitalisierung um es ganz konkret zu
machen in bezug auf disruption
digitalisierung ist in wahrheit
diskussionen die digitalisierung wird
die alten geschäftsmodelle alle auf den
kopf stellen mit daten basierten
instrumenten und dafür brauchen wir
junge menschen mit gehirnschmalz mit
lust auf zukunft
die sagen gibt sie wollen ihre idee
umsetzen ihre ziele ihre projekte ihre
vision und die müssen die
rahmenbedingungen haben dass dieses
funktioniert beispielsweise durch eine
gründer schutzzone dass wir sagen in den
ersten ein zwei jahren müssen sich junge
menschen auf ihr geschäftsmodell
konzentrieren und nicht auf bürokratie
und wenn wir nach 23 jahren sehen das
funktioniert gut dass in deutschland aus
das ist nachhaltige zukunftsorientierte
politik und darauf müssen derzeit
stellen und das ganze funktioniert nur
und erschließt sich die
indem wir an der haushaltskonsolidierung
festhalten
die cdu csu bundestagsfraktion steht zu
der schuldenbremse weil die
schuldenbremse das entscheidende
disziplinierungsinstrument ist damit
auch wir uns an regeln halten damit wir
nachhaltig auch im lichte dessen was die
nächsten generationen noch brauchen
nämlich spielräume politik machen können
und deswegen halten wir an der
schuldenbremse fest sie ist übrigens es
ist übrigens auch wichtig im
europäischen kontext
deutschland muss weiter vorbild bleiben
ja in sachen konsolidierung
haushaltskonsolidierung europa darf
nicht auf schulden oder billigen geld
aufgebaut sein sondern erstens auf
stabilität zweitens auf solidität und
drittens auf gemeinsame regeln
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
ex trainer kollege klaus ernst die linke
frank sprecher für wirtschaftspolitik
der linksfraktionen herr präsident meine
sehr verehrten der linie jetzt habe ich
schon mal frage wohin sie auch
wirtschaftsministerium war nämlich schon
einen bei euch ich habe den eindruck da
hab ich hatte eher den eindruck
märz gesprochen ich wundere mich warum
alle den job vom alten rollen
viele fühlen sich berufen nur wenige
sind geeignet kann ich da nur sagen
meine damen und herren ist sieht eine
dramatische lage
der wirtschaftsbericht macht nur zum
teil deutlich wir haben drei prozent
wachsen prognostizierte halbmayr ob das
wirklich so kommt hängt an der pandemie
oder nicht zögern die füße wir wissen
dass wir 3,6 milliarden täglich für den
walk down brauchen
und jetzt kommt das eigentlich
dramatische frau merkel spricht
inzwischen von einer naturkatastrophe
andere vom schock meine damen und herren
nur durch ein rasches impfen von 70
prozent der bürger nicht nur bei uns
sondern eigentlich der welt können wir
diese pandemie bekämpfen
wir haben auch deshalb zu wenig
impfstoff weil die unter normalen
bedingungen sind folgende regelungen zum
patentschutz ein hochfahren der
produktion behindern
ich weiß nicht ob sie vorgestern
handlungsplan angeguckt haben die
indische regierung begleitet inzwischen
laut handelsblatt folgenden umstand ich
will ihnen das zitat bringen
die indische regierung beklagt eine
weltweite verzögerung in den
impfprogrammen wegen mangelnder
impfdosen werden gleichzeitig geeignete
produktionsanlagen in vielen ländern
nicht genutzt werden könnten weil das
geistige eigentum an den impfstoffen
geschützt sein
also an regelungen die hindern
aus dieser pandemie herauskommen der
alpen hat uns frau merkel
und da muss man doch mal darüber
nachdenken ob die bremsen wollen dass
man da vielleicht ein stück weiterkommen
ich bin nicht der erste der vom krieg
gegen das widerspricht ich bin auch
nicht der erste der von krisen
produktion bricht das war der fdp-chef
lindner ab und zu auch mal was richtig
ist
meine damen und herren und daher
ausnahmsweise mal recht hat wir sind
nicht im normalbetrieb frau
bundeskanzlerin herr alba es muss alles
unternommen werden um möglichst rasch so
viel wie irgendmöglich dieser impfstoff
zu produzieren und zugänglich zu machen
die sonst richtigen die sonst richtigen
regeln der freien marktwirtschaft
richten sich jetzt gegen die interessen
der menschheit diese krise ist
persönlich und wirtschaftlich nur zurück
wenn man das ändern
ich appelliere an sie setzten sie bitte
setzen sie bitte diese regelung zum
patentschutz und aus und greifen sie ein
in die vergabe von lizenzen
wir haben genug kapazitäten auf dieser
welt das hier möglichst rasch
tatsächlich alle durch insel gründen da
muss man aber den stecker sozusagen
reinstecken dass auch die kapazitäten
genutzt werden können meine damen und
herren und ein und ein letzter eine
letzte bemerkung erhalten hat zu diesen
40 prozent die sie immer haben nach
deckelung der kosten für sozialabgaben
ist wie ein weg aus der krise
sie haben gestern im ausschuss dieser
habt ja wir machen es deshalb dass wir
so lange die lohnkosten billig halten
dann gibt es nicht so viel
rationalisierung weil die unternehmen
dann lieber arbeiten nehmen statt
maschinen meine ich damit ja hier
altmaier wissen sie das pferd für
altmaier wie auch dann vom traktor
ersetzt worden
wenn es versprochen hätte weniger zu
fressen und zu saufen und genau
und genau das ist ja zusammenhang genau
das ist er zusammen haben ist wir
brauchen gegen für mehr beschäftigung
andere lösungen als die die sie
vorschlagen so vorschlagen herzlichen
dank fürs zuhören
nächster redner ist der
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90 die
grünen dr anton hofreiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wahrscheinlich
nie war in einer debatte zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht so eindeutig
was die prioritäten für die nächsten
wochen und monate sein müssen
die erste alles aber auch wirklich alles
dafür zu tun
die endgeschwindigkeit zu beschleunigen
es gibt aktuell für unser land für
europa für die ganze welt keine
wichtigere aufgabe angesichts der
enormen kosten des lok downs ist die
beste wirtschaftspolitik alle ressourcen
zu mobilisieren um endlich ausreichend
impfdosen zu produzieren jeder monat im
lockdown kosten uns zehn milliarden euro
500 millionen pro arbeitstag und das nur
für deutschland
wir müssen jetzt klare signale setzen
für eine maximale ausweitung der
produktionskapazitäten
und dies am besten global aber europa
muss da jetzt sofort vorangehen
wir können in den nächsten monaten
vielleicht jahre gar nicht genug
impfstoff haben
zumindestens global nicht und klar ist
angesichts der gefährlichen mutationen
mehr denn je dass wir mit 19 erst
besiegt haben wenn wir mit 19 weltweit
besiegt haben dafür müssen wir jetzt
massiv finanzmittel zur verfügung
stellen wir können eigentlich wenn man
ehrlich ist dafür kaum zu viel geld
ausgeben und dafür müssen wir jetzt
ideologiefrei jedes instrument prüfen
kooperation hat natürlich vorrang aber
auch verpflichtende vergabe von lizenzen
müssen jetzt auf den tisch und dafür
braucht es eine globale task force bei
der g20 mit der neuen beiden regierung
sind die chancen dafür so gut wie lange
nicht und leider und leider habe ich
zweifel dass sie liebe bundesregierung
das mit dem nötigen nachdruck verfolgen
anfang januar hat die kanzlerin endlich
eine arbeitsgruppe dazu eingesetzt
seitdem hat man davon nichts mehr gehört
ich kann sie nur auffordern machen sie
das zu allerhöchsten priorität folgen
sie der devise whatever it takes und
auch die zweite priorität ist eigentlich
klar eine stringente pandemie bekämpfung
und wieder wird der widerspruch bemüht
zwischen panini bekämpfungen wirtschaft
und kaum sinken die zahlen rufen die
ersten schon wieder nach lockerungen das
ist falsch und vorschnell
die wirtschaft braucht nachhaltige
lockerungen keine voreiligen denen geht
es um verlässlichkeit und planbarkeit um
eine perspektive und wenn wir zu früh
lockern
dann haben wir doch in kürzester zeit
wieder zahlen die völlig außer kontrolle
geraten sind
das haben wir doch inzwischen in
dutzenden von ländern weltweit erlebt
deshalb lassen sie uns noch einige
wochen klar auf kurs bleiben und damit
es klar ist eine beibehaltung des
shutdowns darf keine ausrede sein
anderes nicht zu tun
er führt mit zwei masken für alle zu
günstigen preisen
endlich luftfilter in den schulen
digitalisierung der gesundheitsämter
voranbringen und massenhaft schnelltests
strategisch eingesetzt
all das muss jetzt kommen schnell um mit
nachdruck
und drittens sorgen sie endlich für eine
schnellere auszahlung der hilfen sagen
sie endlich für eine echte
existenzsicherung für selbstständige und
sagen sie endlich für windows
kurzarbeitergeld
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
trotz alledem bleibe ich optimist wir
werden diese pandemie dank wissenschaft
dank modernster technologie in diesem
jahr in den griff bekommen und danach
stehen unser land vor weiteren großen
herausforderungen
klimaneutralität digitalisierung den
wettbewerb mit china
die neue zusammenarbeit mit den usa die
modernisierung unserer infrastrukturen
wird und verwaltung das jahrzehnten nach
dieser pandemie muss eine dekade des
aufbruchs eine dekade der gestaltung und
der modernisierung werden
dazu brauchen wir eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung von staat wirtschaft
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern und
der gesamten gesellschaft
und dafür brauchen wir mehr
investitionen
privat aber auch öffentlich der staat
muss mehr investieren im breitband in
quantencomputern und spitzenforschung in
neue schienen in ladesäulen
wasserstoff-infrastruktur entschulden
und kitas die rufe danach aus der
industrie aus der gewerkschaft sind laut
und eindringlich hören sie endlich
darauf und ihr kanzleramtsminister helge
braun hat er am dienstag in ihren augen
die unverschämtheit eine offenkundige
wahrheit auszusprechen
wir werden nach der krone pandemie und
angesichts dieser herausforderung nicht
einfach zu alten schuldenbremse
zurückkehren können ich kann ja
verstehen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union dass sie kurz vor dem
wahlkampf ihnen das recht ungelegen kam
aber ich bitte sie lassen sie uns eine
offene eine an der sache orientierte
debatte dazu führen eine vielzahl von
ökonomen die experten der oecd die
gewerkschaften die industrie sie alle
sagen lasst uns die schuldenbremse
beibehalten aber sinnvoll
weiterentwickeln wir schlagen
wir schlagen dazu eine investitions
regel vor
das ist nachhaltige haushaltspolitik und
eine ganzheitliche betrachtung auf der
höhe der zeit
lassen sie uns das gemeinsam anpacken
getreu dem motto erst kommt das land und
dann das partei oder fraktion stockmeier
vielen dank das war der optimist anton
hofreiter der fraktionsvorsitzende der
bündnisgrünen hat gesagt das land steht
vor großen herausforderungen das
jahrzehnt nach der pandemie ist das
jahrzehnt des aufbruchs und es müsse
mehr investiert werden auch von der
öffentlichen hand und daher sei die
schuldenbremse weiter zu entwickeln
nächste rednerin in der debatte sie ist
mitglied im haushaltsausschuss für die
spd sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn ich die
100 ca 160 seiten des
jahreswirtschaftsberichts kurz
zusammenfassen kann oder wenn man es
kann dann würde ich das an drei punkten
tun
ich würde als erstes feststellen wollen
dass die wirtschaftliche prognosen und
die arbeitsmarktlage ist besser ist als
die wirtschafts expertinnen und experten
als vorausgesehen haben
zweitens wirtschaftshilfen in nie
gekannten ausmaß investitionen in
forschung und entwicklung die
auswirkungen der krise gemildert haben
und drittens ein starker sozialstaat
sich als der stabile faktor in der krise
bewährt hat richtig als richtig hat sich
erwiesen dass es richtig ist und
notwendig ist nicht gegen eine krise
anzusparen indem man sozialleistungen
kürzt sondern es ist richtig zu
investieren in sozialleistungen und wir
haben es getan zum beispiel an dem
kurzarbeitergeld hubert h
der arbeitsminister sitzt dort wenn wir
es nicht getan hätten wir kein
kurzarbeitergeld haben würden wissen wir
dass wir viele millionen menschen mehr
in die arbeitslosigkeit gebracht hätten
ist es ist es jetzt ein grund sich
zurückzulehnen zu sagen ist ja alles gut
9 ist es privaten nicht mehr erinnern
uns sehr genau an gesprächen des letzten
jahres fehlende masken fehlende
beatmungsgeräte und seit neuestem
fehlende halbleiter in der
automobilindustrie und ich habe sehr
viele automobil stadtwerke bei mir im
wahlkreis deren länder jetzt im
augenblick still stehen deshalb müssen
wir doch ans feststellen
die zunehmende oder große abhängigkeit
von globalen märkten in deutschland und
in europa beschleunigt krisen und
deshalb müssen wir genau dorthin schauen
herr altmaier
wenn wir die zukunft unseres standortes
des industriestandorts sichern wollen
und wenn wir arbeitsplätze sichern
wollen wie sie es ja auch gestern wieder
im wirtschaftsausschuss gesagt haben und
uns als spd ist es wichtig dass
deutschland an stabiler
industriestandort bleibt das will das
land der industrien und der industrie
bleiben
deshalb müssen wir alles daran setzen
das liefer- und wertschöpfungsketten in
deutschland und in europa erhalten
werden beziehungsweise aufgebaut werden
es darf die stadt schwachstellen die ich
genannt habe nicht geben herr altmaier
wir müssen sie identifizieren als erstes
wir müssen darüber reden und uns
anschauen was haben wir für produkte und
was brauchen wir für die produktion ist
die lieferung schwierig brauchen wir
dort eigene eigene produktion die wir
aufbauen müssen nehmen sie gerade dem
bereich arzneimittel in der
gesundheitswirtschaft das will ich ihnen
noch mal ans herzlich
das ist ihre aufgabe auch als
wirtschaftsminister
wir haben da schon
darüber diskutiert und da sehe ich
defizite und deshalb meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wenn wir den standort
deutschland auch in der zukunft stark
erhalten wollen wenn wir arbeitsplätze
erhalten wird brauchen wir ein blick in
die zukunft brauchen wir handeln für die
zukunft und das heißt sich um
wertschöpfungsketten um lieferketten zu
kümmern und antworten zu geben da sind
sie gefordert der minister herzlichen
dann der bundestag debattiert über den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht 20 21 3 prozent
wird prognostiziert im herbst ist
übrigens 4,4 prozent gerechnet der
nächste redner in der debatte ist
stephan petry sprecher für wirtschaft
und energie der afg fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren sehr geehrter
herr minister altmaier sie und die
bundesregierung vertreiben die zukunft
aus deutschland muss man leider so sagen
in diesem bericht den können wir getrost
zur seite legen sehe ich nichts was
wirklich zukunftsweisend sein könnte und
sie behandeln eben heute in ihrer rede
probleme die wir ohne das falsche
handeln der bundesregierung nicht hätten
denn die korona die pandemie ist nicht
schuld daran dass die wirtschaft jetzt
schwierigkeiten hat sondern die falschen
maßnahmen die die wirtschaft behindert
das ist das problem und das ist eben
auch redlicherweise der bundesregierung
zuzurechnen
herr minister altmaier sie handeln wie
ein alchimist sie verkaufen uns die
schaffung zukunftsfähiger arbeitsplätze
obwohl diese hochsubventioniert sind sie
verkaufen uns marktwirtschaft obwohl wir
immer weiter in die planwirtschaft
abgleiten sie verkaufen uns wachstum
obwohl wir längst vor corona schon in
die rezession geschlittert sie sind
nennt und sie verkaufen uns die
sogenannten klima rettungsmaßnahmen und
die sogenannte energiewende als chance
obwohl diese werte vernichten meine
damen und herren
obwohl diese keine werte schaffen und
auch noch die unternehmen hier aus
deutschland vertreiben aufgrund der
versorgungssicherheit und der hohen
energiepreise und als detail wollen sie
uns einen aus wasserstoff produzierten
stahl als wettbewerbsfähig verkaufen
obwohl genau das gegenteil der fall ist
und sie verkaufen uns nachhaltigkeit
obwohl die mittlerweile aufgelaufenen
verpflichtungen deutschlands
substanzverzehr und raubbau bedeuten die
stiftung marktwirtschaft beziffert die
nachhaltigkeitslücke also die
verpflichtung des deutschen staates
gegenüber den deutschen bürgern und dem
ausland auf 3 145 prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes und das war im
sommer 20
20 die zahl hat sich erhöht also das
dreieinhalbfache der jährlichen
gesamtwirtschaftlichen leistung und wie
wir wissen kann davon ja immer nur ein
ganz kleiner teil für die tilgung von
schulden und den verpflichtungen
genommen werden
also werden diese verpflichtung
vermutlich nie erfüllen können und die
konsequenz wird sein inflation und
enteignung der bürger und unternehmen in
diesem staat dann ganz nachher als
schreckensszenario geben sie uns einen
anderen ausweg dass wir sehr schön ich
sehe ihn aber nicht 11,9 billionen euro
die die verpflichtungen sind insgesamt
wie wollen wir die den schultern
das ist die ganz große frage und die
realität sieht eben traurig aus die
bundesregierung sie wenn man das der
altmaier vertreiben die zukunft aus
deutschland die autoindustrie
beispielsweise jahrzehntelang rückgrat
der deutschen wirtschaft hat millionen
arbeitnehmer in lohn und brot gebracht
und ohne not wird dieser industriezweig
jetzt abgebaut der verbrennungsmotor
verteufelt das kostet uns laut ihren
eigenen berater bis zu 400 10.000
arbeitsplätzen und anstatt lieferketten
und die rohstoffbasis der deutschen
industrie zu sichern beschäftigt sich
die bundesregierung lieber mit
quoten mit gander quatsch und mit
haftbar machen deutscher unternehmen für
fehler ausländischer unternehmen
und daran kann man sehen wo die
prioritäten in dieser bundesregierung
liegen und die sind grundfalsch wir
vermissen ja ein zukunftskonzept das
umfassend ist und dahin sollte sich die
bundesregierung wenden dass wir
deutschland strukturell auch fit machen
und wir haben sie an ihrer rede gesehen
sie haben sich also wirklich mehr mit
den selbst gemachten schäden hier
beschäftigt und nichts mit
zukunftsweisenden technologien zum
beispiel und daran müssen wir arbeiten
und als detail jetzt fehlen uns also in
unserem land mikrochips für unsere
autobauer und sie mussten einen brief
schreiben nachteil waren sie mussten
also in taiwan betteln dass unsere
volkswirtschaft entsprechend beliefert
wird
und das ist unsere volkswirtschaft nicht
würdig das ist unwürdig für unsere
industrie nationen dass wir das nicht
selber hinbekommen meine damen und
herren die bundesregierung vertreibt die
zukunft aus deutschland wir sollten
diesen bericht der hier vorliegt einfach
beiseite legen die armen hochkrempeln
und die probleme strukturell angehen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner der kollege dr joachim
pfeiffer cdu csu
[Applaus]
also herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht ist in der tat
ja immer gelegenheit zurückzublicken was
denn im letzten jahr gut gelaufen ist
oder wo man sich verbessern kann und
auch immer ja der auftakt was im
kommenden jahr
denn angepackt werden soll und auch ich
lieber kasten haben wir es noch mal
angeschaut werden
genau vor einem jahr am 30 januar wir
waren ständig zusammen in einem haushalt
kessel am 30 januar letzten jahres haben
wir auch hier den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht 2020 diskutiert
und da ging es darum haben wir jetzt ein
prozent wachstum 1,1 oder 1,2 herr
kollege theurer hat die kurzarbeit auf
beschworen und gesagt die wäre
explodiert einzelnen sektoren
verzehnfacht
die zahl nochmal angeschaut sie sind in
der tat vom januar 2009 10 auf den
januar 2020 von 354.000 auf 382.000
gestiegen
es war damals viel aber wenn man jetzt
mal erzählt und auch tal kassel in mainz
angesprochen sechs wochen später hatten
wir lockdown weitere sechs wochen später
hat man nicht 400.000 sondern über sechs
millionen menschen in kurzarbeit
und deshalb ist glaube ich klar wie
herausforderungen division wir stehen
und die politik hat gehandelt gemeinsam
gehandelt und ich glaube deshalb sollte
man auch vielleicht insgesamt etwas
demütiger sein
in meinem letzten jahr erlebt haben das
ist nicht nur in unserer hand liegt was
den auf uns zukommt und da müssen wir
vielleicht auch entsprechend damit
umgehen
wir haben
gemeinsam dann ins schaufenster gestellt
ein viertel bis ein drittel des
sozialprodukts 1,2 billionen euro 1200
milliarden euro um hier zu helfen
soforthilfen eine brücke zu bauen in der
wirtschaft um die sozialsysteme am
laufen zu halten und deshalb kann man
sagen heute ist erfreulich anders als in
vielen anderen ländern der welt ist die
arbeitslosigkeit nicht explodiert die
zahl der sozialversicherungspflichtigen
beschäftigten ist leicht zurückgegangen
und insgesamt haben wir gott sei dank
keine sozialen verwerfungen und anderes
mehr das ist gut und erfreulich aber
darauf können wir uns nicht ausruhen
weil und das ist heute in der debatte
noch nicht angesprochen worden in
anderen teilen der welt in anderen
ländern es trotzdem
obwohl sie auch die krise haben dort
sich sogar ausgebrochen ist es weiter
voran geht
während wir in deutschland 2020 fünf
prozent - haben gibt es in china 2,3
prozent wachstum
während wir in deutschland 9,9 prozent
weniger exportiert haben haben sie in
china trotzdem im letzten jahr 3,6
prozent mehr exportiert während wir 8,6
prozent weniger importiert haben wurde
in china nur ein prozent weniger
importiert während wir in deutschland im
moment weniger als 20 prozent des lukas
auf kommentaren als vor einem jahr
lassen china im september oktober wieder
100 prozent und im moment ungefähr 80
prozent hängt natürlich auch mit dem
größeren einen markt und der größe des
landes zusammen und an
mehr keine frage das heißt auch dass wir
zur wahrheit dazu in china geht es voran
und wir rudern im moment zurück und
deshalb müssen wir schnell und
entschieden gemeinsam handeln dass es
keine weiteren fessel mehr gibt sondern
dass wir entfesseln und deshalb ist das
was das was der koalitionsausschuss
eigentlich mal beschlossen hat nämlich
ein belastungsmoratorium zwingend
einzuhalten und zu diesem
belastungsmoratorium gehört sagt es noch
mal für unsere fraktion in aller
deutlichkeit keine steuererhöhungen die
wird gift jetzt in der krise
sie sind gift auch nach der krise für
wachstum und beschäftigung
es gehört aber auch dazu dass wir kein
lieferketten gesetz machen wie
privatrechtlicher haftung ihr in
deutschland weshalb nichts
das hilft nicht den menschenrechten
sondern im gegenteil wir hatten sie in
der letzten debatte schon es führe dazu
dass beispielsweise in afrika unsere
unternehmen dann doch verdrängt werden
nun andere dann das geschäft machen zu
schlechteren bedingungen als es bei uns
der fall ist wir brauchen auch kein
umwandlungs verbot in bauland
immobilisiert mobilisierungs gesetzt
weil das gegenteil der fall ist es
würden weniger wohnungen gebaut und
damit ist es auch mit schädlich und es
galt das eigentum an
wir brauchen in der tat auch solide
finanzen länder zukunft und hofreiter
nein das können wir sich doch anschauen
da müssen wir mal gar nicht irgendwie
uns was neues einfallen lassen
2008/2009 ich zu beobachten wie die
importe weiter sogar noch zurückgehen
und die exporte als es jetzt der fall
ist wie die wirtschaft nach unten ging
und wir auch schwierige situationen an
und dann war es klug und richtig danach
entsprechend solide zu wirtschaften die
ausgaben stabil zu halten
und entsprechend dann wachstum zu
generieren dynamik auszulösen was wir
auch jetzt tun dass wir mehr
steuereinnahmen hatten um entsprechend
herr kollege gegenteil weil der kollege
schneider würde gerne eine zwischenfrage
stellen
carsten schneider lieber petit kollege
pfeiffer wir sind ein jahr ist
wirtschaftsdebatte ist ja mit seinen
gesetzentwurf des kabinetts aufgegriffen
zum bauland modernisierungsgesetz das
war nachher gleich diskutieren und
gesagt der kernpunkt die umwandlung von
der verbot das aroma von mietwohnungen
in eigentumswohnungen trägt die fraktion
nicht mit ist das für die gesamte
bundestagsfraktion ist können wir die
debatte nach er absetzen oder tragen sie
das tut was das kabinett mit ihrer
bundeskanzlerin auch getragen gut
beschlossen hatten
[Applaus]
es geht die exekutive und es gibt die
legislative und ich glaube es war einer
ihre fraktionsvorsitzenden der wahl
gesagt hat kein gesetz verriss den
bundestag so wie es in den bundestag
nein kommt und es wird auch für das
bauland mobilisierungs gesetz gelten
weil unser idee und unsere vorstellung
ist dass wir mehr bauen wollen dass wir
eigentum zum eigentum ermutigen wollen
und nicht hörten aufbauen wollen die
dazu führen dass im ergebnis weniger
gebaut wird dass das eigentum gefährdet
wird und das ist die falsche antwort
darauf
deshalb werden wir alles dafür tut dass
dies bauland mobilisierungs gesetz nicht
so ins gesetzblatt kommt die es im
moment
der vorschlag ist um was geht es um
entsprechende dynamik auslösen leider
bleibt auch bei mir geht die uhr relativ
schnell voran nicht mehr viel zeit aber
die dynamik auszulösen im bereich des
handels und das sage ich auch anderen
koalitionspartner noch mal beendet wir
hatten kürzlich die debatte und die
anhörung im wirtschaftsausschuss zum
freihandel zur ratifizierung von zehn
anderen dort hat der frühere außen- der
wirtschaftsminister sigmar gabriel
gesagt wenn wir es nicht mal mehr
schaffen mit einem land wie kanada
was sind vielen bereichen europäischer
ist als manche mitgliedsstaat der
europäischen union ein umfassendes
vorbildliches freihandels und abkommen
zu schaffen mit wem soll muss dann noch
nach
das ist auch die aufgabe der museen was
in china was in anderen regionen in der
welt vorangeht dann müssen wir hier auch
alles geben das freie märkte und
entsprechendes wachstum und damit
generiert wird hiermit wir wollen
dynamik auslösen und lösen das aus mit
mehr warten des kapital bei startup bei
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren die
gießhalle
sie ihren dauerhaft beschleunigen umlage
befreiung wasserstoff campus netze bei 5
g vieles weil sie mir noch vorgenommen
zu sagen aber wie gesagt die zeit ist
schneller vorangeschritten
wir warten auf jeden fall diese dynamik
nutzen müssen damit auch hier wieder
nach vorne routern und nicht zurück und
damit die lücke zu anderen in der welt
nicht größer sondern kleiner dafür
lassen sie uns gemeinsam kämpfen
naja hat einen spd-fraktionsvorsitzenden
zitiert das war peter struck der leider
viel zu früh von uns gegangen ist das
deutsche gesetz lautet kein gesetzlich
verlässt das parlament wie es
hereingekommen ist
hier geht es um den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht der sprecher
für wirtschaftspolitik thomas lutze von
den linken hat jetzt das wort
sehr geehrte damen und herren herr
präsident die krise zeigt dass sich in
der wirtschaft vieles verändert hat
viele selbstständige und kleine
unternehmen stehen vor einem
scherbenhaufen
wenn ihre märkte zusammenbrechen und
selb und selbstständige unverschuldet in
existenznot geraten
dann geht das nicht ohne die solidarität
der gesellschaft langfristig helfen ja
keine hilfszahlungen wir brauchen eine
echte arbeitslosenversicherung auch für
selbstständige und unternehmer denn die
welt ist eine armutsfeste als
absicherung aller menschen notwendig
sieht man dass menschen in hartz vier
obdachlose und geringverdiener besonders
betroffen sind dann muss man ihnen einen
zuschlag von mindestens 200 euro
gewähren
damit wäre ihm geholfen dieses geld
fließt eins zu eins in die wirtschaft
zurück weil es direkt konsumiert wird
das zu verweigern ist nicht nur
unsolidarisch es ist auch
wirtschaftsfeindlich wir haben uns
jahrelang dynamisch erklärt heute wieder
wie wichtig die schwarze null sei das
hat schon fast religiöse züge
da wäre es doch eine gute idee wenn sie
den gedankenblitz des
kanzleramtsministers braun aufgreifen
würden der diese frage zumindest kurz
diese frage zumindest kurzfristig in
frage gestellt hat also geben sie sich
doch mal einen ruck die schwarze null
ist weder in der krise noch danach ein
geeignetes wirtschaftspolitisches
instrument
wie kann es sein dass die wirtschaft im
frühjahr 2020 wochen land nicht in der
lage war
einfache medizinische schutzmasken
herzustellen wurden da aus profitgründen
lebenswichtige produktion ins ausland
verlagert den leuten hat man erklärt
dass es sich die masken selber nehmen
könnten nun trauben auf einmal dieses
selbst genähten masten nichts mehr
damit wird auch vertrauen verspielt
deshalb gibt es jetzt nur eins verteilen
sie die schützenden masken an alle und
das kostenlos im vergleich zu den
gesamtkosten der pandemie sind das
peanuts der erde damentag gesundheit ist
auch so ein wirtschaftsbereich der an
seine grenzen gestoßen ist viele
krankenhäuser würden
kapitalmarktorientierte ausgerichtet sie
müssen sechs bis acht prozent
wirtschaftsreferent dieter
erwirtschaften
wir brauchen aber krankenhäuser die
gemeinwohlorientiert arbeiten deshalb
gehören alle krankenhäuser in
öffentlicher trägerschaft
eine der wichtigsten fragen ist aber wir
haben zeit die folgen der krise
fest steht dass konzerne wie amazon
genau durch diese krise ihr vermögen von
viele fahrten der aktuelle oxfam bericht
sagt dass der spalt zwischen arm und
reich immer größer wird
da ist es doch nur logisch dass die
profiteure der krise zur kasse gebeten
werden die linke fordert diese
herrschaften an den kosten finanziell zu
beteiligen
den oberen zehntausend die werden es
verkraften wenn man ihren
unbeschreiblichen reichtum ein ganz
kleines bisschen begrenzt doch das setzt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gut
voraus geht ja mehrheit im bundestag
fehlt vielen dank das nicht gelaufen
thomas nutzen daraus mit www für die
erreichen steuer der bundestag
debattiert nach wie vor über den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht 20 21 meine
damen herren aber wir werden gleich aus
gegebenem anlass ganz kurzes
innenminister verlassen erst mit nichts
direkt nach dem urteilsspruch im
mordfall lipke hier wieder bei ihnen
melden doch zunächst hat noch das wort
timon gremmels genau von der spd aber es
kann sein dass für ein jahr unterbrechen
wird nicht nur wirtschaftsminister
gewinnen auch energie minister und zu
diesem punkt haben sie im
jahreswirtschaftsbericht und hier heute
gar nichts gesagt was ein falls
gestreift ich finde das ist zu wenig
beim thema e mobilität geben ihnen recht
batteriezellen forschung und ansiedlung
hier das ist gut das ist
wirtschaftspolitik aber die
entscheidende frage bei der e-mobilität
ist doch wo kommt der strom her de
fahrzeuge tanken meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und der muss aus
erneuerbaren energien kommen
herr altmaier und da haben sie gar nicht
so gesagt herr könnte man jetzt sagen ja
wir haben uns wir haben eine andere
krise ganz weit vorne die korona krise
die panini krise das ist richtig aber
dafür gehen ja andere krisen nicht weg
die klimakrise ist doch trotzdem noch da
und wir haben jetzt die einmalige chance
beide krisen zeitgleich zu bearbeiten
sehr geehrter altmaier liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das muss doch unsere
aufgabe sein wenn wir jetzt investieren
müssen wir nachhaltig investieren das
sichert arbeitsplätze das schafft gute
shops meine damen und herren unterhalten
wir sie haben gerade eben gesagt wir
können uns nur umweltschutz leisten wenn
es der wirtschaft gut geht das ist zu
kurz gedacht nur mit nachhaltiger
umweltpolitik nur nach mit nachhaltiger
industrie politik können wir
zukunftsfähige arbeitsplätze schaffen
die uns aus der krise holen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und dazu
brauchen wir jetzt im nachgang zum eeg
eine schnelle umsetzung des
entschließungsantrags der großen
koalition
wir müssen jetzt sozusagen die
aufbauphase für erneuerbare energien
klar durchdeklinieren ja und wir können
zum beispiel in der photovoltaik die
eine große akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
hat sozusagen ein zubau von zehn bis
zwölf gigawatt pro jahr
das schafft arbeitsplätze meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren auch in
deutschland und das zeigt ein blick zu
mir nach nordhessen die studie der uni
kassel hat mal untersucht von 2000 bis
2018 die investitionen in erneuerbare
energien 4,4 milliarden euro in 18
jahren 43 prozent der kosten sind in der
region geblieben das heißt es ist vor
ort eine wertschöpfung von knapp zwei
milliarden euro geschaffen worden das
ist nachhaltige industriepolitik wie wir
sozialdemokraten uns vorstellen
herr altmaier und da muss die koalition
noch ein bisschen mehr tun
eine möglichkeit wäre zum beispiel zu
sagen wir investieren auch wieder
verstärkt in die modulproduktion von
solarzellen hier gibt es ansätze in
sachsen sachsen anhalt eine industrielle
produktion aufzubauen
die 3000 arbeitsplätze schaffen kann
wenn wir 10 2 fußabdruck vergleichbar
wie die franzosen einführen damit wir
hier auch die wertschöpfung in
deutschland halten das übrigens machen
dollar ab mitte der zwanziger jahre für
die batteriezellen kommen was für
batteriezellen gilt muss auch für module
gelten das ist nachhaltige
industriepolitik meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren also unser
abschließender appell ist lassen sie uns
nachhaltiges die politik und die
bekämpfung der hungerkrise
gemeinschaftlich voranbringen beides
können wir zeitgleich leisten das wäre
für die deutsche wirtschaft das wäre für
umwelt und nachhaltige industrie ein
wichtiger punkt so schaffen wir die
krise zu lösen wir das in diesem sinne
glückauf alles gute
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren und jetzt aber
doch noch ein bisschen zeit hier im
bundestag zu bleiben da würde das gerne
tun den jahreswirtschaftsbericht andreas
lenz jetzt für die cdu csu vorsitzende
des parlamentarischen beirat für
nachhaltige entwicklung und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht liegt vor und
dass wir in einer schwierigen lage sind
dass wir uns in einer der schwersten
krisen seit ende des zweiten weltkrieges
befindet das ist ja überhaupt keine
frage
vor einem jahr war die gemengelagen 18
jahren aufschwung noch eine gänzlich
andere das zeigt aber eben auch dass man
krisen nicht in diesem sinne voraussagen
kann oder eben auch ausschließen kann
aber man muss auf krisen gerüstet zahlen
und das ist man am besten durch
finanzielle solidität und auch deshalb
ist der hinweis der sachverständigen
richtig dass bei einer zukünftigen
verbesserung der wirtschaftlichen lage
das augenmerk auf der konsolidierung des
haushalts gelegt werden sollte
und das ist schon ein unterschied grüne
spd und linke wollen die schuldenbremse
abschaffen wir wollen zurück zu soliden
haushalten das ist übrigens auch ein
teil einer generationengerechten einer
nachhaltigen politik meine damen und
herren
die zahlen wurden genannt letztes jahr
hatten wir einen rückgang der
wirtschaftsleistung von fünf prozent in
diesem jahr wird die wirtschaft
voraussichtlich um drei prozent wachsen
und teil der wahrheit ist aus dass der
rückgang in anderen ländern
großbritannien frankreich und italien
mit um die zehn prozent wesentlich
gravierender ist jetzt sind wir aber
nicht zufrieden damit
das ist ja letztlich noch schlechter
laufen könnte wir müssen
schnellstmöglich wieder raus aus der
krise und aus der krise herauskommen wir
nicht mit steuererhöhungen das wäre ja
letztlich als ob man jemanden der gerade
aus der intensivstation entlassen worden
wäre noch mal blut abnimmt wir wollen
steuern nicht erhöhen und sie wollen
letztlich die steuern erhöhen meine
danke während die wirtschaft um fünf
prozent zurückging ging die
beschäftigung lediglich um ein prozent
zurück auch dank des kurzarbeitergeldes
und anderer maßnahmen haben wir die
beschäftigung stabilisiert natürlich
kostet das geld natürlich gibt es
missbrauch den wollen wir und müssen wir
natürlich auch bekämpfen aber hier nicht
zu handeln wäre natürlich letztlich noch
viel teurer
danken möchte ich an der stelle aber
auch all jenen die die wirtschaft auch
jetzt noch am gang halten danken möchte
ich an dieser stelle auch an unternehmen
unternehmerinnen und unternehmen und wir
bekommen wir alle viele anrufe die nicht
aufgeben die weitermachen auch wenn es
schwierig ist auch wenn die hilfen die
jetzt ankommen einen langen anlauf
benötigt haben herzlichen dank an dieser
stelle und ich möchte auch betonen dass
es richtig ist das produzierende gewerbe
auch das baugewerbe weiterlaufen zu
lassen gerade dieses konnte sich auch
während der krise behaupten und wuchs
beispielsweise im letzten jahr in höhe
von 1,4 prozent die wirtschaftlichen
einbußen wären ja sonst noch wesentlich
dramatischer als es das insgesamt ein
wichtiger und richtiger schritt
internationaler handel schafft wohlstand
das geht es mehr denn je zu betonen
gerade auch die wahlen in den usa können
der whu an den neuen schub geben wir
brauchen einen regelbasierten wir
brauchen einen feinen und einen fairen
an den auf nachhaltigkeitskriterien
kriterien gebunden handel
die deutschen exporte sollen in diesem
jahr wieder um 6,4 prozent zunehmen
sollen wachsen wir wollen ein
wirtschaftliches wachstum auch durch
exporte auch durch einen außenbeitrag
meine damen und herren und die grünen
wollen beispielsweise
außenhandelsüberschüsse zwangsweise
abbauen und aus unserer sicht ist das
der falsche weg die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der deutschen wirtschaft zu beschneiden
nur durch innovation kommen wir aus der
krise heraus dass wir bei innovationen
bei grünen
denn letztlich auch gut sind das zeigt
beispielsweise auch die
erfolgsgeschichte des unternehmens bei
und darauf können wir stolz sein darauf
dass brauchen wir brauchen auch diese
positiven geschichten aber auch hier
zeigt sich das kapital kommt von der
anderen seite wie bei beyonce vom
pharmariesen pfizer aus den usa mit
allen nebenwirkungen hormoneller damen
und herren und an der stelle werden wir
uns kurz aus klingen wie schon
angedeutet habe und nicht uns dann
gleich hier zurück sarah bilder und
bunte stärken dass wir auch deutschen
europäischen standards die möglichkeit
geben in deutschland in europa durch
europäisches durch deutsches kapital zu
wachsen meine damen und herren klar
klar ist aber auch ohne die wirksame
bekämpfung von corona wird es auch bei
der wirtschaft nicht wieder aufwärts
gehen da sah man ja auch im sommer wie
schnell die wirtschaftsleistung die der
anstieg als die fallzahlen lässt sich
rapide abnahmen und ein interessantes
beispiel aus der aus dem ausschuss war
ja da hat die afg das beispiel des
positivbeispiel weißrussland gebracht
bei einer pandemie bekämpfung und meine
damen und herren da fällt einem ja auch
gar nichts mehr ein
es ist er ist letztlich eben wichtig
dass wir die pandemie effektiv bekämpfen
dann können wir auch wieder durchstarten
gleichzeitig brauchen wir auch ein
stärkeres denken in szenarien in best
cases in wörth cases was könnte was ihm
passieren wie könnte die wir könnten die
unterschiedlichen perspektiven aussehen
weil das eben auch perspektiven schafft
weil das auch letztlich
planungssicherheit gibt wir brauchen
strategien für das wiederhochfahren der
verschiedenen lebensbereiche der schulen
der kultur aber vor allem natürlich auch
der gesamten wirtschaft wir müssen dabei
weiterhin nachhaltigkeit in allen
dimensionen ökologie soziales und
wirtschaft verbinden wir müssen
letztlich die weichen stellen und dann
wieder aus der krise um dann wieder aus
der krise zu wachsen um auch aus der
krise zu erwachsen
wir brauchen sicher einen ruck aber wir
brauchen zunächst auch ein kräftiges
hauruck das nur gemeinsam zu vollziehen
ist in dem sinne herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
voraussichtlich letzter redner in dieser
debatte ist der kollege dennis rohde spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen stärker als
wahrscheinlich allen debatten um diesen
jahreswirtschaftsbericht in den
vorjahren muss man an diesem jahr
haushalts und wirtschaftspolitik
zusammen denken weil der staat gefordert
war ein zentrales versprechen des
sozialstaates im jahr 2020 und im jahr
20 21 einzulösen nämlich dass wir als
staat in krisenzeiten an der seite der
bürgerinnen und bürgern stehen die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen und wir haben
das als bundesrepublik deutschland mit
großer finanzieller entschlossenheit
getan wir haben uns nicht auf eine
kleine maßnahme konzentriert weil es
auch keine schlüssel maßnahme gibt
sondern wir haben große pakete geschnürt
auf der einen seite die steuerpolitik zb
durch die absenkung der mehrwertsteuer
durch verbesserungen bei den
abschreibungen durch den kinderbonus
gezielt anreize für investitionen für
konjunktur befördernde elemente gesetz
wir haben als stadt selbst investiert
und wir haben für unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer die vor der krise
erfolgreich war
für arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
die vor der krise einen job hatten
brücken gebaut damit sie auch nach der
krise erfolgreich sein können und damit
sie auch nach der krise wieder einen job
haben liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
jetzt kann man natürlich und das gehört
zur demokratie dazu einzelne maßnahmen
kritisieren und man kann sicherlich auch
bei dem riesen katalog den wir gemacht
haben dinge finden die nicht so gewirkt
haben wie sie wirken sollten aber das
was am ende zählt ist doch dass das
gesamtpaket geholfen hat dass wir
wesentlich kraftvoller durch diese krise
gekommen sind dass das
bruttoinlandsprodukt wesentlich
niedriger zurückgegangen ist als das was
wir im sommer noch annehmen mussten wir
gingen davon aus zeitweise dass der
rückgang bei fast acht prozent liegt wir
sind bei 5 prozent genannt wie sind
wesentlich besser durch die krise
gekommen als die euro gruppe in ihrer
gesamtheit die von unserem rückgang aus
den fast 50 prozent mehr
wirtschaftseinbruch gehabt hat und ich
finde dass es etwas worauf wir als
bundesrepublik auch stolz sein können
liebe kollegen
und wir haben dafür gesorgt auch gerade
durch die konjunkturanreize das
unternehmen eigenwirtschaftlich tätig
sein können wir haben genau das gemacht
was man von einer antizyklischen politik
in krisenzeiten zu erwarten hat und wir
werden auch 20 21.1 rekord haushalt
aufstellen wir werden weiter brücken
bauen für unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer für arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer wir sind bis hierher
gekommen und die botschaft ist wir
werden auch in zukunft die menschen in
diesem staat nicht allein lassen wir
werden gemeinsam aus dieser krise
herauskommen und wenn ich das noch sagen
darf helge braun hat ja in einem recht
20 22 jetzt nicht alles vorbei vor uns
stehen riesenherausforderung auch im
investiven bereich im bereich klima im
bereich künstliche intelligenz in der
infrastruktur in der bildung das alles
können wir 20 22 nicht abbrechen und ist
auch als sozialdemokrat klar wir wollen
dass dieser staat auch ab dem jahr 2022
weiterhin ein starker partner für die
bürgerinnen und bürger dass wir sind
nicht bereit bei der sozialen bei der
inneren oder der äußeren sicherheit zu
sparen
und wer das auch so sieht wer findet ab
20 22 würden sparbemühungen des staates
genau das gegenteil auswirken nämlich es
würde unserer wirtschaft staaten der
muss eben hier vielen dank zara hier
spricht im moment noch dennis rohde aber
er kommt langsam zum ende ist auch der
letzte redner hier in der debatte zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht 20 21 peter
altmaier hat heute morgen eine
regierungserklärung dazu abgegeben die
wachstumserwartung müssten etwas gesenkt
werden von 4,4 prozent auf 3 prozent
aber peter altmaier ist ob er mich
optimistisch dass schon im kommenden
jahr die wirtschaft wieder auf vorkrisen
niveau agieren kann